[Music]  Linkin Park singer Chester Bennington  has committed suicide according to TMZ  he was reportedly found at his residence  in the Los Angeles area on Thursday  morning the father of six children  Bennington was 41 years old Linkin Park  formed more than 20 years ago with  Bennington joining the group as frontman  in the late 90s they had multiple hits  together including crawling and in the  end Linkin Park's new album one more  light was just released in May and  during appearances Bennington and the  group had performed tributes to singer  Chris Cornell who was a close friend  cornell committed suicide  that same month brother chris the day  Bennington was found July 20th  would have been Cornell's 53rd birthday  [Music]  you